in Ukraine of Russian missiles have
struck the essendonetsk region killing
at least seven people and turning six
injuring 67 donetsk's Governor says the
missiles hit residential buildings in
the city of provost a hotel used by
Foreign journalists was also hit for
rescue operations were temporarily
suspended due to the risk of further
shelling
will it speak now to Sebastian who's
alive for us in the western city of
etruscovets and so can you just tell us
a little bit more about these targets of
this attack and the Damage that it's
caused
well what happened is a so-called double
tap attack happened on the city center
of pokos in a short interval two
missiles were targeted at the city
center with around 10 to 15 minutes in
between and rescue workers and policemen
who went to the scene are now among the
victims at least 30 rescue workers and
police are injured and also some of them
are among the dead so there were
residential areas apartment building but
also hotel and a restaurant also often
visited by volunteers and a journalists
that was also had the damage is a
significant huge destruction there in
the city center and the security forces
and also rescue workers halted their
operation last night due to the danger
of more attacks so there could even be
more people buried under the rubble and
not only there but also in hakif and
Hassan there were attacks overnight and
also there have been casualties and this
all comes after the Jeddah talks were
finalized in Saudi Arabia over the
weekend Ukraine said there was some
progress there but also now the
president's office in Kiev has denied
some reports that Ukraine has been made
making some concessions especially
regarding the withdrawal of Russian
troops as a condition for peace talks
there were some reports saying that
especially also to bring countries like
China to the table but now the
president's office says those reports
are not true okay thank you so much for
that update that is typical for us in
Ukraine thank you